i wish the puppets would talk more about
the alphabet
not for me but if any kids are watching
a
b and so forth
you know
m l o
p
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
b is for barack is president
you are black sadly i'm gonna give him
after about c is four
d is for dead
b is for
everybody here
[Music]
why didn't i go to business school f is
four roll me once
strike one
but fool me twice
strike three
g is four god gave me this dundee
and i feel god in this chili's tonight
h is four happy birthday jesus sorry
your party's so lame
i is four i
declare
bankruptcy
j is for jessica did you just fart
and that is how it's done k is for
cleven he told dwight a mistake plus
cleveland gets you home by seven
he was home by 4 45 that day l is four
m is for michael
oh that's funny michael
n is for no god
no god please no no
no
no
o is four oh my god okay it's happening
everybody say com what's the procedure
everyone what's the procedure
he is for bam bam bam q is for question
what kind of bear is best
that's a ridiculous question false black
bear well that's debatable there are
basically two schools of thought fact
bears eat beets
bears
beets
battlestar galactica bears do not
what is going on what are you doing r is
for r e s p speed d
find out what it means to me
s is four
t is four that's what she said
don't you dare u is four uh a little
comment
hmm
v is for victim of a hate crime
stanley knows what i'm talking about
that's not what a hate crime is well i
hated it a lot okay i w is for
www.creedthots.gov dot www backslash
creed thoughts
check it out x is for x factor
or whatever it is you want to call it y
is four
z is four
oh wow
that's so rude i'm sorry i can't control
him yeah he can you know i get pam
for this
you